hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe today we're doing
the Q&A video associated with idea
number six which is space time we
actually have a lot of good very basic
questions things that I honestly could
have covered in the original video so
let's just dive right in to them one
question is is time this maybe is more
appropriate for the time video then for
the space time video but still is time
possible without change this is a very
common question so I understand where
this question comes from but I think
that the answer is pretty basically yes
yes it is here's where the question
comes from imagine that you were in a
universe where nothing changed literally
nothing happened right you could have
stopped you could have an arrangement of
matter in the universe but that stuff
was exactly in the same configuration
doing exactly the same thing namely
nothing at every moment of time in that
case the entire idea of the time
dimension is completely beside the point
right it doesn't actually represent
anything if there's nothing different
from moment to moment in time then in
some sense time doesn't play any role
and therefore can we just say time
doesn't exist
but I think that's a little bit going
too strong I mean after all the whole
point of the space-time video was the
time is kind of like space so imagine
you know there's a planet with a person
on it and another planet planet a planet
B another person on it and that's a
terrible person I can do better than
that come on and the point is that
there's space in between them right
there's the vacuum of empty space
there's nothing going on in between them
but nobody would be tempted to say
there's no space in between them right
space we think of pretty naturally as
having an independent existence this was
a controversial topic back in ancient
times right whether or not the vacuum
could really exist or not but certainly
in our post Einsteinian world or even
our post-newtonian world space exists
it's out there even if there's nothing
happening I would say the same thing is
true about
even if there's nothing there even if
there's nothing actually changing with
time
you should still say that time exists
because time is kind of like space time
is part of the four dimensional manifold
where things happen you shouldn't
privilege your being able to notice
something happening just in order to say
that something exists space-time is
something that is a fundamental
ingredient in relativity you know we
take it as existing in addition to the
role it plays we can imagine and we
often talk in theoretical physics about
space times with nothing in them right
completely empty space times but both
space and time exists then and in fact
space and time can have properties even
when nothing exists like the curvature
of space-time we've been talking about
special relativity which is an example
of space-time with zero curvature but in
general relativity you can have space
times that are still static and have
nothing in them that are vacuum but are
not flat and they are still existing in
some very real sense so I don't like to
confuse time with change it's true that
in this fake universe where literally
nothing ever happened
time would not be important it wouldn't
play a role but nevertheless it could
exist it's a real thing in from the
relativity point of view space and time
are both real things both part of a real
thing which is four-dimensional
space-time okay so that's something that
was pretty easy but it's a it's a common
thing so I thought we could get rid of
it the next one is a little bit trickier
but it also is something that just comes
up over and over and over again so let's
dive into it photons do they really
experience no time this is a question
and what does it mean if you say that a
photon experiences no time and so forth
and this is visit tricky one because I
think that there's more than one
possible confusion that is entering in
here so let's start by actually saying
what is true okay what is actually real
so here is our space-time diagram
space-time and we have a way of
measuring intervals in space-time so if
you take our origin right here and
there's
light-cone that we conventionally draw
up 45 degrees one of the questions that
was asked was why 45 degrees well what
would you do right what else do you pick
you can draw whatever you want you could
have different coordinates where light
cones could be at anything 45 degrees is
a very natural thing given that the
speed of light is the only invariant
special speed in this particular way of
doing things in a relativistic
space-time so then given that we can
talk about different paths different
little segments of space-time connecting
to different points there's one little
path let's draw another one between here
and here let's say and let's draw yet
another one between here and here let's
say and this is actually going to answer
another question that that's coming up
later this yellow path let's zoom in
here this yellow path is what we call
time like because it moves mostly in the
time direction this green path is what
we call space like for the same reason
it moves mostly in the space direction
and this orange path we call null or
light like for obvious reasons and these
are all imaginable paths through space
time when I say path I don't mean a path
a particle can actually take we pause it
in most theories of physics that no
particles can move on space like
trajectories that they could they'd be
called tachyons tachyon as a particle
that it's completely hypothetical in the
sense that it probably doesn't exist
tachyons our particles let me say that
would move on space like trajectories
but they don't exist so therefore they
don't move on space like trajectories
and we think that real particles either
are light like massive particles or null
massless particles but regardless of
whether hoops
trajectories can I do this yeah can i
but if they're good regardless of
whether a physical particle can move on
one of these pans we can still talk
about the length of one of these pans
and as you noticed we measured the
length differently for time like pads or
for space like pads because there's a
minus sign that comes in right so for
time like pads let me just erase this
little note about tachyons because it's
just in the side it's not really crucial
talking about here okay these three
kinds of trajectories you know we want
to measure how long they are and we use
different ways of doing it so for a time
like trajectory the measure of how long
it is is the time elapsed the time that
an actual clock moving electric turi
would measure if it were a good clock
and so we say tau has the property the
tau squared equals T squared minus x
squared if the if the trajectory is
curved then we have to take this sort of
tiny infinitesimal version of this and
then we integrate it using calculus as
we learned long ago but this is the sort
of finite straight line version for a
space like curve we don't want there's
no clock that can possibly move on it
right but we can measure its length so
we talk about the length let's say L in
Cola L and L squared is x squared minus
T squared because the point is you're
defining something in terms of what it
is squared right so you want to be able
to take the absolute the square root of
it and therefore you better ensure that
the ving you're taking the square root
of is a positive or at least nonzero
number right
not a negative number so you don't get
an imaginary number you don't want the
time or the space to be an imaginary
number so that's okay these are the
definitions you define the time elapsed
to be the square root of T squared minus
x squared you define this facial length
to be the square root of x squared minus
T squared you get a positive number
either way but then what that implies is
that for null or space law or time like
trajectories x squared equals T squared
so x squared minus T squared equals 0 so
therefore whether or not you do in terms
of tau
orell you get the tau equals 0 or L
equals zero the reason why I'm going
through this in the grisly detail here
is because this is the fact this is the
truth right we're gonna try to translate
this mathematical fact into
comprehensible English words but this is
the thing that is true and we should
rely on it if you're confused about what
the English words mean go back to this
this is the fact there are trajectories
in space-time which we label as null or
light-like they're ones that we say are
moving at the speed of light and they
have zero length in terms of space-time
interval and zero time elapsed in terms
of space-time interval okay those are
the facts now there's another fact which
is that photons move on such
trajectories and therefore the space
light space-time interval along the path
taken by a photon is 0 again that's a
fact that's a real good thing that
you're allowed to say space-time
interval along the photon trajectory is
zero now what you would like to do what
you're tempted to do is to translate
that into a statement that photons do
not experience time and I think that's a
completely correct statement to make
photons don't experience time but let's
be clear electrons don't experience time
either in a very real sense and electron
moves on a timelike trajectory it's a
massive particle it moves more slowly
than the speed of light but let's take
seriously the word experience okay you
and I can experience time because we are
complicated because things are happening
in us from moment to moment as time
changes we change along with it that's
part of what it means to experience time
in some very real way an electron is
exactly the same particle from moment to
moment in time it is not changing its
mass is not changing its charge is not
changing it does not have any internal
complexity that can keep track of the
passage of time so it's a little bit
anthropomorphic to use a word like
experience when you talk about what is
happening to an electron what you can
say confidently is that there is a
space-time interval associated with the
path of the electron along which the
time is a positive number okay that's
the thing
and saying you could also say if you
took a clock and put it next to the
electron so you complicate the electron
by making it a clock if that clock would
tick a certain number of seconds or
minutes or whatever and that would be a
positive number and you can use this
mathematics to measure what that method
what that positive number would be or to
predict what it would be you can't
really take a clock and move it along
with a photon because imagine what
you're trying to do for one thing the
clock would itself have to be a
collection of photons it can't be a
clock that is a massive clock otherwise
it wouldn't be moving at the speed of
light right and there it's a true
statement that if you just have a bunch
of photons moving along next to another
photon there's no change that happens
within those photons not from inside
than their individual cells but from the
point of view of someone outside who is
not moving along with the photons they
can see change the photons need not be
completely oriented in the same
direction as each other so that they
could be moving apart from each other
and moving closer again what you're
tempted to then say is okay let's build
a clock out of photons let's let them
interact and tick back and forth but
guess what as soon as those photons
start interacting they form a system
that is no longer massless that is no
longer moving at the speed of light you
can't build a clock purely out of
photons you can almost do it by like
putting photons in a box and watch them
bounce back and forth but guess what the
box is not moving at the speed of light
and the size of the box are crucial to
building that clock so the point I'm
getting at here is that you're running
up against our intuitive notion of
experiencing time versus the actual
reality of a photon moving all by itself
through the universe it's correct to say
photons don't experience time but then
you want to like take that a little bit
too seriously and then you want to ask
like well but the photon is a wave right
isn't a photon electromagnetic wave
known electromagnetic waves go up and
down well a photon is not a wave light
is a wave a photon is the particle that
you observe when you actually measure
that electromagnetic wave very very
carefully this is a feature not of
special relativity but of quantum
which we will get to and of course the
electromagnetic wave goes up and down
from our perspective as it passes us by
we can imagine seeing it go up and down
but if you just follow along the crest
of that wave nothing is changing no time
is passing from that point of view so I
would just not worry too much about the
internal life of a photon that is my
that is my advice
you can either worry about that and wrap
yourself in in riddles and mysteries
about what the photon sees and
experiences or you can stick to the
things that are actually true in the
math namely that there are space-time
intervals that we can calculate and when
you calculate them for a photon you get
zero everything hangs together there but
there are related questions to this that
make perfect sense
what about photon momentum because we
define momentum well we didn't define it
this way but we said that in classical
Newtonian mechanics momentum was P
equals m times V right now V is the
speed of light but the mass of the
photon is zero so it seems like this
might be zero so maybe a photon can't
have moment but that's not exactly right
for two reasons number one this is no
longer the formula for momentum when you
are in relativity when you're in special
relativity okay remember special
relativity changes the rules a little
bit of classical physics is still a
version of classical physics but it's a
modified version it's not Newtonian
version so I don't want to go into too
many details but for a massive particle
the correct formula is MV over 1 minus V
squared over C squared so you see that
as V the velocity goes up near the speed
of light near C one minus V squared over
C squared comes very close to 1 minus 1
which is zero and you're taking MB and
dividing it by zero so you take zero
divided by zero if you have zero mass
and zero in the denominator and you get
an undefined number so this formula just
doesn't apply to photons to particles
that have speed of light motion and zero
max
but there is a formula that does work so
basically let's just let's leave that
there but cross it out for a photon it
turns out that you can go back to the
electromagnetic wave right that has a
wavelength and talk about the momentum
in terms of that and the answer is that
it is H over lambda where lambda is the
wavelength of the Associated
electromagnetic wave and H is Planck's
constant which is characteristic of
quantum mechanics then you can translate
this if you want something that looks
more like the ordinary formula for
momentum this looks like H divided by C
the speed of light times the frequency
so a higher frequency vibration for the
electromagnetic wave corresponds to more
energy more momentum in the photon okay
but this is this is sort of weird
because you somehow need to have quantum
mechanics to talk about the momentum of
a photon why is that when after all
electromagnetism and special relativity
are completely classical yes but photons
are not completely classical right
photons are particles that you get when
you quantize the electromagnetic wave so
if you talk about electromagnetic waves
you can talk about a density of momentum
and there's a formula for that but a
wave is spread out all over the place if
you want to idealize it as a particle
you need to be thinking quantum
mechanically and H Planck's constant
comes into the game but you do get these
very nice formulas ok that was a much
more down-to-earth question let's get
crazy again
what about could there be more than one
dimension of time this is always a busy
favorite question let's just say could
there be two dimensions of time after
all we say that space-time is
four-dimensional meaning there are three
dimensions of space and one of time but
we often talk about simple idealizations
where there is only one dimension of
space or two dimensions of space and
modern theoretical physics goes up to
you know nine dimensions of space or
just arbitrary numbers of dimensions of
space that we could imagine and we talk
about that fairly straightforwardly
about it several videos ago so why don't
we ever talk about multiple dimensions
of time well you know whenever you ask
questions like could there be the answer
is usually it depends it depends on what
precious ideas you're willing to keep
and which ones you're willing to let go
of so when there are more than two
dimensions of time here is what happens
like it's very hard to try to figure out
how to actually plot this how to draw
this I did not succeed but let me just
draw rather than drawing a spacetime
diagram let me draw a time time diagram
t1 and t2 okay so let me can imagine let
me maybe maybe I can do this let's see
if this works
I can imagine space going
perpendicularly to both things okay so
here's all of space when all represented
by X and the point is when you only have
one dimension of time but multiple
dimensions of space then as long as
you're moving slower than the speed of
light you are moving forward in time you
are forced to move forward in time
that's the implication of this
light-cone picture over here right
someone said could I draw the light
cones as three dimensional but you know
I think that should be pretty obvious at
every point there's a little light cone
that looks like this that has a cone
shaped structure if we imagine promoting
our X to XY and Z and so forth and the
different numbers of dimensions so
that's the that's the fact if you want
to go slower than the speed of light and
move then you will move forward in time
there's only one direction to go in
but imagine starting you know at some
time t1 but there's a whole nother
dimension of time and you have X and you
say well I move at a certain speed in
the T direction but that's the
combination of t1 and t2 I need to move
at least as fast in T as I do in X but I
could easily just go in a circle empty I
don't need to move in X at all right
that counts as moving in time without
moving in space at all I'm moving a lot
more in time than in space so that's a
time like trajectory right that would be
in a loud trajectory but this is what is
called a closed timelike curve this is a
something that becomes interesting also
just in the context
of a single dimension of time but when
you have time machines and general
relativity so I mentioned wormholes some
time back this is the kind of thing that
you'd be talking about in the technical
literature it's a little it seems a
little fear-mongering or sensational to
say time machine so you say closed
timelike curve if there were more than
one dimension of time you could easily
just go around in circles in time you
could meet yourself in the so-called
past your personal clock ticking forward
as you move is completely compatible
with just doing the same thing over and
over again in the universe and that's
generally thought to be bad you know you
can't go back and forth in space I mean
sorry you can of course do a circle in
space but do not meet yourself because
you're forced to go forward in time but
if there were more than one dimension of
time you could just go in circles and
meet yourself in the past that is
generally thought to be bad this hasn't
stopped people from completely thinking
about it there is a physicist at USC
University of Southern California
Itzhak Bars who very famously has
explored the physics of theories with
two dimensions of time it's a whole
thing hope program he has called two
time physics and basically he kind of
cheats he kind of does not allow for
behavior like this so he puts in two
dimensions of time there's a restriction
on what kind of motion you're allowed to
do so this kind of bad behavior doesn't
really happen so I think that physically
realistically two dimensions of time or
more or just a bad idea but you're
allowed to think about it and honestly
you know what do we know you should be
open-minded about these things
my bet is that there's only one
dimension of time but if someone comes
up with a really brilliant version of
physics or quantum gravity that involves
more than one dimension I'm certainly
willing to take it seriously okay here's
another question that we got which is a
fun one this another one this is again a
more down-to-earth question how do you
add velocities in special relativity so
there's the famous idea that you know
you're on a train or a car or something
here you are and your train is moving at
some speed v1 and here you are on the
train and you throw a ball
at a velocity which to your perspective
that is from the rest frame of the train
moves it velocity v-two and the whole
point a big big deal in special
relativity is you don't just add the
velocities together in the usual way so
the Galileo way of doing it in Galilean
relativity you would say the total
equals v1 plus v2 they just add together
but you know that in special relativity
this can't be the right answer because
in particular the speed of light is the
same to everybody so if you rather than
throwing a ball on the train if you turn
on a flashlight and point put light
moving in that direction then v2 would
be equal to the speed of light but the
total speed that the speed that you
would be observing by someone that would
be observed by someone outside the train
there they look at this and see the
total speed V total they would not take
the speed of light and add it to v1
because that would give you a number
bigger than the speed of light and the
whole point special relativity is
everyone gets the same answer for what
the speed of light is so you can go
through you know there's a set of
mathematical derivations you can go
through and you talk about the length
contraction and the time dilation and
everything but I'm just gonna skip right
to the answer the relativity way of
doing it this is kind of cute to see is
that you just replace this formula there
is another formula that you get so the
answer is that be total equals v1 plus
v2 divided by 1 plus let me get it right
v1 times v2 divided by C squared the
speed of light squared okay so think
about this let v1 and v2 get closer and
closer to the speed of light remember we
talked about limits when we talked about
calculus you don't want to just plug in
v1 equals v2 equals the speed of light
you can and in this particular case but
the more careful rigorous way to think
about it is to let them get closer and
closer and see what happens then from
this formula the total
approaches C plus C divided by 1 plus C
squared divided by C squared okay this
is math you can do this is C plus C is 2
times C C squared divided by C squared
is 1 1 plus 1 is 2 so this is divided by
2 so this equals C okay so in
relativistic additions of velocities
when you take one velocity that is close
to the speed of light and add it to
another velocity close to the speed of
light the total velocity is still close
to the speed of light and the reason why
is because the formula for adding
velocities is a little bit different
nothing crazy about that I mean is a
little bit crazy but nothing nothing
hard to understand about that ok the
final question I want to talk about is
this is this is another perennial
question why is the speed of light 300
million meters per second several people
thought that I'd made a mistake I said
the 300 million meters per second is the
speed of light I make mistakes all the
time I've made several mistakes in the
earlier videos when I make mistakes I
try to put errata up there in the show
notes for the video on YouTube
I'm taught by YouTube experts so they
shouldn't do that what I should do is
put a comment in the YouTube video and
that the comment will rise to the top
and people will see it no one reads the
show notes that I put up there that's
perfectly clear because people keep
asking me you know where is the what is
the background image where does it come
from that information is always up there
in the show notes but no one reads those
so yes so this was not a mistake because
I know why you think it's a mistake
because you're used to seeing that the
speed of light is 300,000 but you're
used to seeing this 300,000 kilometers
per second so 300,000 kilometers per
second is 300 million meters per second
I wanted to use meters per second so I
wanted to use both meters and seconds as
good human scale sizes because I wanted
to draw all the light cones in units of
meters and seconds just to illustrate
how different it is anyway the point is
why is it this number rather than some
other number so there's sort of two
ways you could imagine answering this
question one way is you could just be
obstinate and you could say well C is
always equal to one C is just equal to
one light year per year that's always
true and or one light-second per second
or whatever units you want to use these
are the natural units that physicists
tend to use where the speed of light is
set equal to one and you don't worry
about meters and seconds but that rubs
people the wrong way you know that the
ability that we have to choose units
doesn't change the fact that in the
units that we generally use like meters
and seconds the speed of light has a
certain value but the point of this glib
obstinate answer is that I'm allowed to
turn the question on its head the
question you should be asking is not why
is the speed of light 300 million meters
per second the speed of light is the
speed of light it is the fundamental
speed limit in the universe the question
you should be asking is why do we use
meters and seconds right why do we use
those units in our everyday lives and
the answer which I already gave away I
actually also gave this answer in a
recent ask me anything episode of the
mindscape podcast so I'm going to repeat
it here because it's also relevant here
meters and seconds are very natural
units to use for human scale things
because people are a couple meters tall
and when someone pokes you and you react
takes you about a second to react right
it takes you out a second to do
something in the world so if you think
about the typical spatial scales and the
typical temporal scales of the world
meters and second seconds are very
natural units to use just like you know
feet and seconds would be it doesn't
really make much of a difference so the
real real question you want to know is
why in terms of ordinary human scale
activities does the speed of light seem
so big and why is it the specific big
number that it is 300,000 versus 200,000
etc so the reason why it seems big is
biggest human beings are slow I'm sorry
about that I don't mean mentally slow
picking up new ideas but we move slowly
compared to the speed of light right we
are massive objects that relat
Leeloo temperatures we've settled down
right in the very early universe things
were so hot that the atoms the protons
and neutrons electrons were all zipping
around very very close to the speed of
light but the universe has cooled down
since then you've cooled down in a very
fortunate way for the existence of life
life cannot really exist very
comfortably in the mega hot plasma of
the early universe and so we are
lumbering slow beings moving slowly
compared to the speed of light and
therefore it's very natural to us that
the speed of light is big ok but then
you you want to be a little bit more
personally than this you want to say
well but why that specific number why
given the units that are natural to us
is it 300 million versus some other
number you know and again in some here's
the thing let's put it this way when you
whether or not you want to use meters
and seconds or anything else when you're
measuring the speed of light it is a
velocity which means is a distance
divided by time which means we use
something to measure it with right we
use some standard measure of distance
and some standard measure of time ok and
so standard measures of distance come
from atoms it's the basic laws of
physics that set the scale for lengths
in the universe there's a size that a
typical hydrogen atom has you know the
Compton wavelength of the electron the
masses we'll learn when we get to
quantum mechanics there's a relationship
between the wavelength of a particle and
its mass and so the mass which is a
fundamental unit of nature fixes its
wavelength and therefore that wavelength
is a way that we can measure things the
distances that we measure come from the
fundamental parameters of nature the
same thing is true for time you can
imagine an atom doing a certain
transition from one energy level to
another and you can say things like well
how frequently does that happen that's a
kind of crude but possible way to
measure time you can also say when that
happens and an electromagnetic wave is
released if I know the wavelength of the
light then I can just measure the
distance between the peaks and troughs
of the actual wave and get a
students from that so I can get either
if I know the distance I can get the
time if I know the time I can get the
distance but the point is that our
fundamental units of measuring both
space and time
come from the fundamental laws of
physics by which I mean the masses and
energies of the fundamental particles
therefore when we measure the speed of
light we do so secretly in terms of the
sizes of atoms and the frequencies of
light they emit and the rate at which
different radioactive processes happen
and stuff like that we use the
fundamental laws of physics to measure
the speed of light in this particular
way so what a lot of people I'm building
up you know this this sounds all kind of
obvious but I'm building up to the
question could C be different could it
be different elsewhere in the universe
or could it change over time right could
the speed of light have been different
in the past or in the future so there
are theories where this is true VSL
variable you know you can guess what
this means right variable speed of light
theories I'm not myself a big fan of
these theories so let me explain why I
really think you know when I make the
glib joke that the speed of light is 1
I'm not just joking you can always
choose units in which the speed of light
is 1 there's a very real sense in which
to say the speed of light is changing is
strictly nonsense
because I can always choose units in
which the speed of light is 1 it is the
speed with respect to which I measure
other things but that's the point
the point is that I can imagine changing
other things like the charges and masses
of different elementary particles in
exactly such a way that the only
observable effect in the universe is
that the way I measure the speed of
light would be different you know from
someone's point of view the speed of
light is changing the same but the
masses of protons and electrons and the
electric charge and the strength of
gravity and all that stuff all that
stuff is changing over time the speed of
light is constant from one person's
point of view from another person's
point of view in this kind of
all that other stuff is remaining
constant but the speed of light is
changing these are completely equivalent
ways of talking you can always trade off
a purported change in the speed of light
for a set of changes in other constants
that exactly conspire to make it look
like the speed of light is changing so
people have thought about these theories
Albrecht in and magazi Oh famously wrote
some papers about this stuff and but it
never really caught on I think that's
the reason why the point is that if you
just change perspective from you're
changing the speed of light - you're
changing every other constant of nature
in just such a way that it conspires to
make it look like the speed of light is
changing that seems a lot less
compelling the the point is that when
you really dig into what the speed of
light is you shouldn't think of it as
something that is fixed in terms of
meters and seconds you should think of
it as something that is cooked into the
fabric of space-time itself it defines
what space-time is everything else is
relative to the speed of light rather
than the speed of light being relative
to some absolute fixed thing we don't
have absolute fixed distances and times
but we do have an absolute fixed speed
in the universe and that's why I don't
really like to think of the speed of
light is changing but you're allowed to
that's the short version of that okay
finally finally I'm not going to
actually answer this but there are many
questions about curved space-time so I
did the video about space-time and then
secretly I just did it about special
relativity which is the particular idea
that there is a flat space-time that is
a background that is absolutely fixed
and unchanging of course over the course
of ten years Einstein went from that
point of view to general relativity
where he says that space-time has a life
of its own it can respond to energy and
to matter and we interpret that response
as gravity so a lot of people ask
questions about black holes or the Big
Bang or light cones in different kinds
of space times and stuff like that I'm
just indicating here that I'm not
entirely blowing you off but I want to
talk about those questions in an
entirely different video in different
contexts I'm gonna I'm gonna give
gravity and curved space-time it's due
ok that
is a topic that deserves a video of its
own so for space-time itself that's all
I gotta say
space-time being flat is still a big
enough idea that it qualifies as one of
the biggest ideas in the universe